story and the setting let's take a look  at the trailer  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  well look at that a brand new assassin's  creed game set in china it looks amazing  uh matt can you tell us a little bit  more about the features  well for the first time in our open  world games you can create your own  character you'll get the chance to do  things like parkour atop the great wall  of china sneak through bustling cities  engage in intense combat and discover  the secrets of vastness of ancient china  well that leads me to my next question  so mac many of us know that a netflix  show is in development and the community  would like to know more what else can  you tell us well it's still early in  development but i can confirm that we  are co-developing the netflix series